Mẹ bà tháng buổi năm 2019, chiếc xe định xe ông bị su bẩy ơn tra gặp nạn và bốc trẻ tại thành đô.
Chúng khúc khiến năm tại sẽ tử vong.
Theo tức gọi điều tra, bà xe trước từ điểm và trạc, chiếc xe trẻ với tụi khoảng 2.8 kí lồ mấy trình dở.
Giảm xuống còn buch trong 6.9 kí lồ mấy trình dở tại từ điểm đâm vào xe phi trước và giảm còn buch trong 8.8 kí lồ mấy trình dở khi tông vào dài phân các.
Nhưng người thăm gia thứ ộ không thể mực sự xe sau hệ thống định bị mất nguồn.
Cử dụi xe không thể mở tụi bình hỏi vì bà trạc hiện hiện thống định á thấp mất nguồn làm vô hiệu hóa chức năng mở cửa bằng tay nắm.
Bà cao cũng lưu gió, xe được trong vị nút mùa cửa định đi ngoài, khi không có tay nắm cơ khi hình tất có thể hòa đậu khi mất định.
Chức hiếng lồ hại vì vấn đề an toàn, bố công việc ở cơ người thông tin trong quốc đã sợ thảo vụ tư trên bắt mục mỗi đứa tây nắm cửa ổ tổ.
Thuy định mối, được phép dụi xe vào thăm 1 năm 2021, các cầu tất cả cửa xe phải đục trong vị tay nắm cơ khi có thể mang động ngày cà khi mất định, bà của mồng cả trong Trungua Piên tập sức của hoặc xe ra hệ thượng mất kiểm soát nhìn.
Các niềm sản xuất có thể hạn đến năm 2018 bệnh để á sụ quý định này cho các bẫu xe bối và đến năm 2019 xử thiết kế đối với các bẫu xe đã giám mắt.